National Institutes of Health is
launching a study to learn more about
how the corona virus affects children
while most kids have milder symptoms and
adults not all do our senior medical
correspondent dr. taryn the ruler now
reports on what doctors hope to learn in
the study I would never like picture me
having to be into being and being in the
hospital
sixteen-year-old Carla Duarte is a
coronavirus survivor the high school
junior from New York is one of the
relatively few children in the u.s. to
have severe complications from kovat 19
her numbers were not improving her
oxygen level was not improving doctors
told Carla's mom Anna
they had one treatment option left an
ECMO machine which pumps and oxygenates
the patient's blood outside the body
when they told me about the machine they
said you know this is after seven days
on ECMO and five more on a ventilator
Carla's condition finally improved she
was sent home after 21 days in the
hospital you never had serious cases
like Carla's are rare complicating the
efforts of investigators we have much
less experience because the children are
just getting less sick so there are many
fewer children interacting with the
healthcare system and being tested dr.
Tina Hart a Vanderbilt School of
Medicine is leading a new NIH study
remotely monitoring about 2,000 children
and their families in 11 cities
nationwide
she says that more data should be
collected before a decision is made to
send kids back to summer camp or school
I think it's really risky to base
decisions about this based on the fact
that children get less sick from this
virus because that does not equal
children being less likely to transmit
the virus we're not completely sure what
are the risk factors for why these
children get sick with koban dr.
Adrienne Randolph is leading a separate
CDC funded study at Boston Children's
Hospital what are some of the
interesting or different presentations
that you've seen in children with over
19 it scattered reports what they're
seeing is cardiac dysfunction so that
their heart's not working as well as it
should an abdominal pain is often part
of the prison
twelve-year-old Juliet daily went into
cardiac arrest after arriving at a New
Orleans emergency room they had to do
two minutes of CPR on her and then they
got her back thank God her mom says she
tested positive for the corona virus and
another viral infection she was in the
ICU for 10 days before recovering
families regarding children and the risk
of Kovich be vigilant be careful it can
become very severe in less than a day
the New York City Department of Health
says there are 15 children in the
hospital with a very rare inflammatory
syndrome that they're saying is
potentially associated with the corona
virus it can involve fever rash low
blood pressure and inflammation of the
blood vessels including the coronary
arteries boy Terrence oh and one of the
more fortunate aspects of this outbreak
is that although we have seen some
severe cases children generally have
more mild symptoms do we know why it's
really fascinating Toni and the experts
say we don't there are a couple of
theories one has to do with the fact
that children may have less of those
AIST receptors or less functional AIST
receptors these are the receptors in the
lungs that the virus attaches to and
gets into the cells that may be why they
don't get sick another theory has to do
with the fact that children are exposed
all the time to lots of other corona
viruses the ones that cause the common
cold so they may be developing
antibodies to those that are cross
reactive to kovin 19 and therefore
helping them and the last has to do with
the fact that their immune system may be
primed just right so they don't have
that overwhelming cytokine storm and
hyper reactive response that's causing a
lot of adults to get into trouble with
kovat 19 but really lots of questions
remain yeah very interesting and of
course we've had questions about the
school year now also questions about
summer camp that's a big one in my
household Tara thank you very much